he was scheduled a course to visit there
meeting President Duda there and a
number of other dignitaries of course
this was the visit that we were all
expecting we weren't what we weren't
expecting was that yesterday he would
come a little earlier and make a pit
stop in Ukraine but we are expecting to
hear from him on camera a little later
today we're going to get a pretty
substantial some speech from him a
little later this afternoon which will
bring you live on Sky News and of course
it comes just after uh President Putin
spoke a little earlier and and Michael's
Clark is still with us at defense and
security analyst and and Michael you
know there's a certain Meeting of Minds
amongst the people that the President
Biden is is meeting there today
what do you think could be achieved at
this meeting well he wants to reinforce
this the message that NATO has United
the European Union is on side as well
and he won't have any trouble with that
in Poland Poland is the leader of the
Hawks in Europe and Poland and the
Baltic State Estonia Lithuania those are
the top fees because they live close to
Russia and they've been saying for the
last 20 years the Russians you know
intend to do this sort of thing so he
won't have any problem there but his
message is really for two audiences one
is the southern Europeans Italy Romania
uh Hungary these countries are a bit
more equivocals in some cases in
hungry's case very equivocal and the
other audience is back home he needs to
show the Republicans back home that
actually he is leading a meaningful
Alliance and this Alliance is powerful
he needs to show that the Europeans are
are taking their share of the burden
because arguably all the the Republicans
in the states they always say look the
Europeans don't pull their weight and
it's true they don't and Biden needs to
show look they are pulling their weight
look at what's being done so I think
there's different audiences for what
he's talking about here just as Putin in
a way was talking to the Russian public
in his creation of what this war was all
about Biden is talking to the American
public and to other members of the
European public about the need for
resilience the need to actually tough
this this out for as long as it takes